fatal blunder an insane blunder and uh
I'm still in shock at what we just saw
during the break with carwana's move
Queen to B4 so two moves ago we thought
that things were going on the upswing
for black a boss-up seemed to be losing
the threat of the game we were
discussing the move F5 which would have
given black great defensive chances but
instead after a 22 minute think carwana
goes on the other side he plays Queen to
B4 trying to attack White's Pawn Center
laterally and completely forgetting
seemingly about the dangerous inherent
on the king side Bishop takes H7 King
takes H7 and the decisive move Knight E4
and the threats of Knight G5 and in some
cases Knight F6
that means the game is essentially over
here ninjata Bossa will see this while
skydiving in his sleep he doesn't even
need the 42 minutes that he has on his
clock this these lines are so easy to
calculate I think Fabiano carono will
stop the clock like right here he might
stop the clock after Knight D5 F6 but
this game is not going to last more than
a couple more moves incredible
yeah shocking development he's resigned
yeah and designed wow
stunning really really really stunning
I think Fabi cannot believe what
happened it's it's clear the tiredness
everything together it was just not not
able to to think with a quiet head with
the calm head which was actually
acquired for this semi-final I mean not
semi-finals uh for third place match